after watching this video you literally
pray that
your opponent do play the modern
scandinavian defense
why
well the reason is very obvious
not only i'm going to show you one of
the most trickiest line against it
but even though let's say your opponent
doesn't fall for the tricks and traps
white get an opening advantage
in almost all the lines
whereupon black is really suffering
[Music]
after e4 and d5
the modern scandinavian rises after e
captures d5 and rather than capturing
back with the queen
black plays the move knight to f6
here white has tried many responses
but i am going to recommend this
fischer's move
bishop to b5 check
well the first thing first if black
continue with knight b to d7 then after
c4 i think white is holding on to his
extra pawn and i don't see a clear
compensation in this line
so that is why as per the database
bishop to d7 has been exclusively played
here
and after this
white's big point is he wants to hang on
to this extra pawn by playing bishop to
c4
okay
now we are at very important junction
where black has tried majority
two of these moves and let's see each by
turn and see whites some amazing replies
the first move b5 roughly played in more
than ten thousand leeches games
and the point is very obvious after
bishop to b3
black wants to play a5
grab every single space on the queen
side and if allowed then he is really
looking for to trap down this bishop by
playing a4
okay
once again white has few choices
but amongst them my recommendation is
very simple
you play the move a4
so that if blacks block it with b4
then we are more than happy to hold on
to this extra pawn
but no
again if you look at the database by far
the most popular choices
b captures a4
where idea is very obvious
if you take the spawn then after knight
captures d5
black is regaining the pawn and
comfortably equalize the game
well here comes the movement guys
fasten up your seat belt as i'm about to
show you
a nasty exchange sack
yup rook captures a4
and i think with the help of modern
chess engine
you can find out such sacrifices
which are not only really strong but
black has to play very accurately
to even avoid the early defend
for example
black is forced to capture this rook
otherwise
he will get some fracture pawn on the
queen side with a clear pawn down
situation
so what else bishop captures a4
and after bishop captures a4
knight b to d7
white has a very silent but the killer
move
knight to f3
and the idea is very obvious
pressurize the d7 knight
well accordingly black has two major
choices
number one knight captures d5
highestly played here
but in fact it's a big time blunder
as after knight to e5
black has two ways to defend his d7
knight
but unfortunately
both of them fails
let's see each by turn so the number one
if you think that knight b6 looks so
good
nope
it's a worst move as after just one move
queen to f3
and suddenly
black is completely losing the game
there is a mate on f7 hanging and the
only way to defend this is by playing
the move f6
but now
yup you guessed it
queen check
g6
knight captures g6
kindly note black cannot take this
knight because queen captures g6 is a
checkmate
so as per the engine the best move is
queen to b8
but after this
very simple continuation
knight captures rook
discover check
king to d8
and finally when white save his bishop
if you count the material
just at the 15th move of the game
white is a pawn and a whole bishop up
isn't that amazing
okay some of you may say
hang on i can play knight to f6
so that i can neutralize the attack on
f7 right
well yep you can accept
nope it doesn't solve the problem as
white indeed continue with queen to f3
whereupon his idea is very simple
he wants to take on d7 and then take the
rook
which is again gives white a completely
winning age
for example if black is foolish enough
to move the rook somewhere
then we have this bishop captures d7
whereupon
black is completely losing as he cannot
recapture with the knight
and the only move queen captures d7
leads to
loss of the queen
so nope that rook cannot move
the base sequence black can play over
here is
c6
but even after this
bishop captures c6
rook to a7
if any time white wish he can take on d7
and get the exchange
but i think
the stronger move here is
knight to c3
where white has a simple plan he wants
to play knight to b5
and get this poor guy
well one of the game from the database
finished very quickly
black plays the move e6
white indeed playing knight to b5
and since this rook now cannot move
black continued with queen to b8
attacking on the e59
but here
white played a very accurate move namely
d4
and after bishop to d6
the simple transaction knight takes rook
queen takes
now you take on d7 with a check
and black is clearly pieced down here
because if you foolishly take this
bishop then after queen check king to d8
and knight to c6
black sweetie disappear from the ball
so these are some of the wonderful high
profile tricks and traps
if your opponent continue with knight
captures d5
well the second most popular choice here
is g6
but even after this
black cannot stop white's onslaught with
knight to e5
and after bishop to g7
[Music]
the lovely move knight to c6
decide the game
black queen has been attacked she has
only one square to go
and then what else
this nice attacking queen e to move
which i'm afraid completely bamboozled
black camp
nope black cannot castle due to this
simple fork
so that is right out of the equation
if you think knight captures d5 walk
here
well guess what just one move
c4
and black cannot move the knight in
order to protect the checkmate
so last but not least the only move here
is bishop to f8
protecting the maid
whereupon although white has many good
options
i think knight to c3 is a fitting reply
which highlight
how pathetically black has been placed
as none of his king side as well as
coincide pieces can move whereupon white
has
all the time in the world
to castle put the rook on e-file
and then generate a big time attack
all in all if you put this position in
any chess engine
it clearly indicate that
black should already resign this game
okay so let's move on to the most
popular choice
namely bishop to g4
played in more than 18 000 leeches games
whereupon black's idea is very simple
if you defend the attack on the queen
by knight moves then the d5 pawn drop
so white response is forced here you
have to play f3
whereupon by far the most popular choice
is
bishop to f5
trying to get the pawn back
okay
we need to protect it by playing knight
to c3
and now black's big idea is he wants to
play knight b to d7
so that this knight is re-routing to the
b6 square
whereupon at the end black is trying to
get his pawn back
with a good position
and yes indeed at first sight this looks
cool
except one problem that
white has this very aggressive reply
g4
attacking the bishop
if knight to b6 then b3 is a very strong
reply
and i have attached a model feed a game
in the pgn
but
once again if you look at the database
here
the majority of the games continue with
bishop to g6
whereupon
white can really trick black
by playing next amazing move
can you guess it
congratulations if you see the move f4
so white's idea is very innocent he
wants to play f5 and take down this
bishop
accordingly black has tried three
responses
but i don't think so neither of them are
working here
for example the first move i want to
consider is
h5
a big mistake
as now white pawn ruler literally killed
the black
first f5 attacking the bishop
bishop to h7
now you play g5
a black played any knight moves then the
h5 pawn drop
for example if knight to b6
attacking our bishop
we can deliver this jack
so that after knight after d7 finally we
can munch on h5
and obtain a two pawn advantage
so that's not a good choice for the
black
and by far most frequent choice is
knight to g4 which i'm afraid
completely fails
due to the following lovely move by
white
d4
look at this
closing all doors for this black knight
so that in the next move we are going to
lash out
with h3
and trap this knight
for example bishop takes f5 h3
and you can walk it out by yourself this
knight is not going anywhere
the second move which is in fact the
most popular choice on the leech ass
that is bishop to e4
completely fails due to the following
easy sequence
knight captures e4
knight captures e4
now you attack this knight with queen to
e2
and when black plays the move knight to
d6
counter attacking our bishop
we can simply respond with b3
so in all these lines not only white
hold on to his extra pawn but his
superior peace development can create
some huge problems for the black camp
for example one of my recent game
where my opponent is nearly 2200
finished very quickly
he played knight to b6 here
i responded with knight to f3
and after knight takes pawn takes
black clearly realized that if he plays
the move e6 or c6
then his position fallen apart
so in the game he continue with one of
the most natural choice
g6
but to his horror he find out that
after bishop to b2
black is forced to move the rook
as if he plays f6 then bishop takes f6
lose another pawn
so rook to g8 what else
now i continue with c5
which forces another black piece to go
back
and finally
the insult to the injury
queen to b5 jack
not only wins another pawn
but look at the center white is
obtaining
and don't forget black is going to lose
one of his pieces
so this 17 more miniature highlight how
difficult black position can become
if he continue with routine move
bishop to e4
finally what happens
if you open and continue with at 6
well this is so easy first you indeed
play a 5
and after bishop to at 7
the nice move d4
confirms white extra pawn advantage as
well as
space in the center
here black can respond with the various
way
but the big factor you have to remember
is this light skirt bishop will always
remain a passing creature
let's see a game to understand
what is the planning of campaign from
the white side
we are following a game between two
grand masters
where black continue with a6
so his idea is to play knight to b6
and then munch on the d5 pawn
so white support the d5 pawn with queen
to f3
and after knight to b6
bishop to b3
black choose the typical scandinavian
route namely queen to d7 and planning to
castle long
okay
white plays knight to e2
allowing black to castle
so that he can play knight to f4
and i think here
you can realize
how problematic this position is for the
black
as
he would love to play the move c6 or e6
but in fact both leads to a catastrophic
mistake
no wonder any black player will be
frustrated from this position
and in the game he indeed lash out with
g5 but after knight to d3
that knight is looking for some juicy
squares
and in fact after bishop to g7
knight to e5
queen to e8
white just consolidate his position
with bishop to e3 and castle on the
queen side
whereupon
after knight f to d7
the tactical blow happen on the board
d6
so by force black has to remove the
knight
but the end result is after pawn capture
c7 check
king takes
pawn takes e5
black was happy to exchange some pieces
thinking that his position will become
better
but nope
just look at white center
completely dominating this bad bishops
and i'm not sure here that black was in
time trouble or not
because in the game
he made this horrible mistake here
bishop captures e5
whereupon
he lose the piece immediately with
bishop captures b6
king captures b6
and queen to e3 check
where end result is
black king is dancing on the highway
and
his species are completely sleeping
that's it guys i hope with this many
lecture
now you're confident enough to meet
the modern scandinavian
remember at this point it doesn't matter
whether your opponent continue with b5
or bishop to g4
against both this lines
as i have shown in this video
you can deliver some nasty surprises
whereupon if black is not careful then
the game can be finished
just within the opening
stage
thank you for watching this video
feel free to like subscribe and comment
and i will meet you in my next episode
very soon
bye and take care